averey Steiner taught himself to paint
it's a kind of therapy when the shadows
of the past haunt him he's the only
member of his family to survive the Nazi
occupation of Budapest of the shallow
get tighter our job ghetto was to gather
up the bodies he got mo get the lawyer
most of them were victims of the air
raids we either had to burn the corpses
or stack them up neatly one on top of
the other for that we were given a kind
of warm water Bellavia that sat in my
office room they called it soup a lot up
aubrey was orphaned at the age of 13 his
father died in the ghetto his mother was
murdered at Auschwitz the Nazis occupied
Hungary in early nineteen forty four and
immediately confined Budapest's 70,000
Jewish residents to a ghetto ivory is
now 83 he lives in a suburb of Tel Aviv
and just about gets by on his modest
pension he spent years in a legal battle
with the German authorities to be
recognized for his time as a forced
labor so he could receive a pension by
the German bureaucracy proved an awkward
hurdle he's got a massage salon is it I
don't want to generalize but I had a
hard time with every office I dealt with
it was beyond me I didn't have the money
nor the mental strength for da luta
cursive el rojo mentally aubrey was
frustrated so he turned to a consultancy
in tel aviv that specializes in securing
compensation for former forced laborers
after checking the claims the firm
forwards them to attorneys in germany
cases can take years to be processed
the Kottam on an Aladdin yes our clients
say why do we have to fight for so long
I see all worked in the ghettos that
selects their cases are sorted and
selected again in this troubled term
selection is they feel they're being
treated like second-class people I've
resubmitted his claim in 2003 it took
seven years and a second ruling from a
federal court for his application to be
accepted he now gets a monthly payment
of 219 euros and twenty cents from
germany's public pension fund ten
percent of that amount goes to the legal
consultancy berlin will be making the
process faster and fairer that was the
promise made by its Minister of Social
Affairs last week as a top level
government delegation led by Angela
Merkel visited Jerusalem new legislation
could be passed within months we
introduced the right to apply for
pensions in 2002 unfortunately many
issues were still unclear and in many
cases the legislation did not meet the
requirements of those affected now we're
trying to simplify the process so that
the majority of individuals are actually
entitled they will now be able to
receive pensions backdated to 1997
annoyances Mukesh Martin that would mean
pensions being upgraded including
aubrey's but the news is still far from
encouraging do some house how do I know
how long I have to live I can't possibly
know that so why does this process have
to take so long it doesn't make sense
how do he go your mother for him mommy
all abri Steiner has left of his family
and home is this one photograph the
pension will not bring them back but he
appreciates the gesture even if it comes
too late